Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Buongiorno a tutti.
Volevo iniziare
questa veloce presentazione -
che si inserisce all'interno
di tutte quelle che contribuiscono,
appunto, a sensibilizzare
e a renderci sempre più responsabili
del cambiamenti climatici -
facendovi vedere questo piccolo terrario,
che costruisce mia figlia.
In questo vasetto, che contiene
un pezzettino di natura,
si intravede tutta la forza e la fragilità
che la natura stessa,
e l'intero nostro pianeta ha.
Vediamo qui, all'interno,
un piccolo ecosistema
in cui tutto funziona correttamente.
Gli scarti,
che sono qualche volta l'ossigeno,
qualche volta la CO2,
vengono completamente riciclati.
Anche l'acqua stessa,
che viene evaporata dal suolo
e traspirata dalle piante,
poi riprecipita e risimula
l'andamento del nostro clima.
A questa forza, che ci indica
quanto la natura sia in grado
di essere presente,
e di funzionare autonomamente,
corrisponde però anche una debolezza,
che chi possiede un terrario
conosce molto bene.
Da un certo punto di vista
si sa che comporre un terrario
è una cosa molto difficile.
Molti che ci hanno provato
hanno visto che il terraio moriva.
E non solo: molti hanno anche
esposto il terrario, magari,
a troppa luce, o a troppo poca luce.
E questo ha, in generale,
causato poi una sorte di morte.
Questo terrario simula, quindi,
un po' quello che è il nostro pianeta.
Ma lo simula interamente?
Be', forse no.
Quello che stiamo notando, recentemente,
è che a causa delle attività antropiche
molte delle azioni che richiedono,
e che sostengono le attività umane,
hanno in qualche modo alterato
l'equilibrio del nostro pianeta,
facendo in modo che il terrario -
che potrebbe essere la nostra terra -
non funzioni più come prima.
In modo particolare,
quello che abbiamo alterato
è proprio il bilancio
dell'energia del nostro pianeta.
E da questo punto di vista,
volevo farvi vedere questo grafico
che esprime l'andamento dell'energia
all'interno del nostro pianeta.
Vedete qui, in questo grande grafico,
la quantità e i flussi di energia
che arrivano dal Sole.
Quel quadrato di destra rappresenta
la quantità di energia solare
che alimenta il sistema climatico.
Da un certo punto di vista,
le correnti, i fiumi, la pioggia,
l'evaporazione dell'acqua,
il movimento dei venti
ed il movimento dell'aria,
dell'atmosfera e delle correnti marine
sono tutte quante generate
da questa energia che arriva dal sole.
Ma chi è attento,
vede che in alto a destra
c'è un piccolo quadratino.
Quel piccolo quadratino lì
sono gli altri flussi di energia:
solamente lo 0,2 percento,
se facciamo 100 percento
l'energia netta che ci arriva dal Sole.
In questo 0,2 percento,
se espandiamo questo quadrato,
troviamo altri flussi:
i flussi, ad esempio, energetici
che derivano dal magnetismo della Luna -
dalla gravità della Luna, scusate;
e i flussi che derivano dalla fotosintesi,
in quel grande rettangolo
verde che vedete lì.
Accanto a questi,
ci sono anche i flussi
che genererà l'uomo:
l'energia che produce l'uomo
attraverso le sue attività.
Vedete che è solo
una piccolissima frazione
dell'energia totale
che fluisce attorno alla Terra.
Ma per produrre quella poca energia,
siamo stati in grado di generare
una serie di alterazioni
che sono soprattutto legate,
appunto, all'effetto serra,
la forzante radioattiva -
cioè l'aumento dei gas
ad effetto serra nel pianeta
che causano un progressivo aumento
dell'energia, che viene del Sole,
che viene trattenuta sulla Terra;
e quindi questo ha degli impatti,
ovviamente, sul nostro clima.
Che cosa possiamo concludere
da questo grafico?
Beh, due cose:
la prima cosa si riferisce
al quadrato di sinistra, quello giallo.
C'è una grandissima quantità
di energia rinnovabile
che possiamo utilizzare.
Già l'energia solare,
i pannelli solari, o l'energia eolica
sta prendendo decisamente piede,
e sempre più piede,
sulla faccia della terra.
L'altra cosa che dobbiamo,
e possiamo notare da questo grafico,
è proprio questo sbilancio
tra l'energia che ci serve,
che dobbiamo produrre,
e l'energia che invece causiamo
e utilizziamo o produciamo
come alterazione all'interno
del sistema climatico.
Per ridurre questo impatto, quindi,
è necessario non solo
che noi diventiamo più sostenibili,
consumiamo meno energia per procapite
ed emettiamo meno gas ad effetto serra;
ma è necessario che noi, anche,
rimediamo a tutti i danni
che sono già stati generati
fino a questo momento,
cioè rimediamo all'aumento
di gas ad effetto serra,
che dall'età preindustriale a oggi
abbiamo effettivamente aumentato.
Sappiamo, e lo sapete -
l'avete, è già stato ripetuto
in tantissime presentazioni -
che la concentrazione
di anidride carbonica
come gas ad effetto serra principale
è passata da 280 parti
per milione a più di 400
in questi ultimi 30, 40 anni.
Che cosa bisogna fare, quindi,
per ridurre i gas a effetto serra?
Sono state proposte
quattro diverse tipologie di intervento.
La prima è quella, diciamo così,
molto tecnologica,
che prevede di costruire
degli alberi artificiali
che utilizzano l'energia solare
per accumulare anidride carbonica,
per trasformare in anidride carbonica
liquida, o addirittura solida,
da poter poi stoccare, immagazzinare,
all'interno di riserve non più mobili,
all'interno dei pozzi petroliferi
o nelle profondità oceaniche.
La seconda tipologia
è quella della afforestazione
e della riforestazione:
effettivamente gli alberi,
attraverso la fotosintesi,
un po' come quello che succede
nel nostro terrario,
usano l'energia del sole per prendere
anidride carbonica dall'atmosfera
e trasformarla in biomassa terrestre.
La terza tecnologia ha un nome strano.
Si chiama BECCS: Bio Energy
Carbon Capture Sequestration, in inglese:
cioè l'energia con accumulo
e sequestro del carbonio.
Consiste, fondamentalmente,
nell'utilizzare biomasse
prodotte attraverso la fotosintesi,
e di produrre una certa
quantità di energia:
ma contemporaneamente,
di catturare le emissioni
che sono sotto forma di anidride carbonica
e di immagazzinare anch'esse
all'interno dei gas ad effetto serra.
Quello che volevo proporvi invece oggi
è qualcosa che è molto simile al BECCS,
ma è qualche cosa
che possiamo fare a casa nostra.
Possiamo fare semplicemente - o perlomeno,
ognuno di noi può contribuire
senza avere un grande impianto.
E si basa effettivamente su questa cosa
che vi faccio vedere qua,
cioè sul poter produrre del carbone
in maniera semplice,
e anche con un elettrodomestico
che è ormai diventato comune
in molte famiglie.
Abbiamo imparato a fare questa cosa
non da poco tempo:
è un'esperienza che ci arriva
dal nostro lavoro in Africa,
in cui abbiamo costruito
un fornello che vedete qui acceso,
un bruciatore che vedete qui acceso.
Che utilizza delle biomasse,
cioè quelle che vedete qui:
ad esempio residui,
scarti di lavorazione dell'olio di palma;
residui del caffè;
o altri residui vegetali
per produrre questo fuoco.
È un fuocherello molto interessante
perché, come potete notare,
non produce assolutamente fumo:
è molto pulito.
E questo bruciatore
è, anche, molto efficiente
dal punto di vista
della conduzione dell'energia.
Questa stessa stufa che qui, vedete,
questo stesso impianto pirolitico
può essere anche utilizzato
e applicato all'interno
di elettrodomestici casalinghi,
cioè all'interno di vere e proprie stufe
che possono essere stufe ad accumulo
o simili alle stufe a pellet
che ormai si sono diffuse
all'interno delle nostre abitazioni.
Qual è la differenza di questa stufa
rispetto a una tradizionale
stufa a pellet?
Beh è quella che alla fine
del processo di pirolisi,
che è quello che produce questo gas,
che vedete bruciare
con questa fiammella gialla
qui nella stufa -
all'interno della stufa
non rimane cenere, ma rimane carbone.
In questo caso, qui vedete alcuni pezzi
di carbone che sono stati prodotti
all'interno di stufe fatte in Africa
o stufe fatte in Europa.
Possiamo quindi immaginare
di utilizzare residui agricoli,
o residui dell'agro industria,
per produrre calore
ma contemporaneamente produrre carbone.
Questo carbone, che possiamo produrre
all'interno della nostra stufa,
è fondamentalmente l'anidride carbonica
che era nell'atmosfera,
che è diventata biomassa vegetale -
e quindi non più gas ad effetto serra -
che è poi diventato carbone.
Un carbone che è ovviamente
una sostanza molto recalcitrante,
cioè difficilmente viene decomposta
e riemessa in atmosfera
sotto forma di carbonica.
Ed è per questo che, effettivamente,
è un metodo molto efficace
di accumulare il carbonio.
C'è un'altra prerogativa
di questo carbone:
che messo all'interno di molti suoli,
può contribuire
ad aumentarne la fertilità.
Sicuramente nei suoli africani
questo effetto è stato già provato:
ma anche nei nostri suoli
o nei suoli dell'orto casalingo
può essere un elemento molto efficace
per migliorare la struttura del suolo.
Dunque, l'idea qual è?
L'idea che ciascuno di noi
possa utilizzare delle biomasse,
e delle biomasse che non derivano
dalla distruzione
di piantagioni e di foreste:
quelle potrebbero rimanere,
diciamo così, ad accumulare,
continuare ad accumulare carbonio.
Ma utilizzano biomasse che altrimenti
si sarebbero decomposte,
come le paglie, come gli scarti del mais,
come le sanse delle olive.
Che trasformate in pellet,
possono essere usate
all'interno di queste stufe -
non viene richiesto un pellet
di altissima qualità -
e quindi possono contribuire
a generare carbone,
che messo nell'orto rappresenta
il nostro piccolo sistema
di carbon storage sequestration
con il quale possiamo contribuire
a mitigare l'effetto serra.
Conclusione di questo mio discorso:
forse alcuni di voi hanno intravisto,
in questa mia descrizione,
la possibilità di costruire
una filiera di valore,
fatta appunto di produzioni di pellet,
di produzione di nuove stufe,
di recupero del carbone
o riutilizzo del carbone come ammendante,
o come addirittura carbone attivo
per filtrare l'aria e l'acqua.
Ma il mio intento non era questo.
Il mio intento era quello
di responsabilizzare,
effettivamente, tutte le persone
a prendere un'azione immediata
per quanto riguarda questo problema.
È qualche cosa che non
possiamo più rimandare,
è qualche cosa che non dobbiamo
necessariamente delegare
alle grandi aziende
e alle grandi istituzioni.
Non per questo voglio lasciare
questa responsabilità
ai singoli individui, è chiaro;
e faccio un appello, in questa occasione,
anche a chi ha la possibilità
di decidere per questa direzione.
Ovviamente un intervento politico
che in qualche modo promuova
queste tipologie di attività,
che crei consenso attorno
a queste tipologie di attività,
è fondamentale per poter poi realizzare
una reazione efficace di mitigazione.
Vi ringrazio.